and i want to talk about chris cuomo
because
we have a story from timcast.com chris
cuomo accuses don lemon and jake tapper
of violating journalism ethics the
reason why i think this is fun to start
off with because it shows the inner
workings at some of these big media
companies cuomo himself he's ousted from
cnn
he's now accusing other employees at cnn
of wrongdoing but he knew they were
doing this while he was there and he
said nothing i'm sure these other people
who work there know they're all doing
things that are bad and considering what
we see consistently with the media lies
i just thought it would be good to start
off today with just
very very uh you know deep breath deep
breath and
they're admitting they're liars i feel
so it's so good chris cuomo now is
backstabbing the organization i'm glad
to see it i am glad to see it too one
thing i think is hilarious though is
chris cuomo coming forward and saying
the people need to know
cnn isn't reliable
someone has to tell them
if not me how will they know let me read
this real quick chris cuomo is seeking
125 million dollars from cnn for
allegedly wrongfully terminating him and
he is throwing his former colleagues
under the bus in his attempt to get it
in his arbitration demand filed on
wednesday cuomo alleged that jake tapper
don lemon former cnn president jeff
zucker and former executive allison
gallest engaged in blatant breaches of
journalistic ethics quote as long as
zucker and gallus believed cnn's ratings
would benefit they were more than
willing to disregard breaches of
traditional journalistic standards by
cnn personalities such as don lemon and
jake tapper or even to engage in blatant
breaches of journalistic ethics
themselves cuomo's filing stated not
that we all didn't already know this but
it's good to hear it and i just want to
point out one more thing in this
document from uh uh from the the filing
i was really hoping it was going to be
on march 15th that cuomo uh issued this
statement the eyes of march yeah but it
was march 16th
so basically what he's saying is he
shouldn't be she he shouldn't have been
fired because everybody else was doing
it and that was the culture there and so
now
it's okay
now like now everybody's in trouble well
no now he's saying like look look how
look they they fired me it was wrong you
know look at what a stand-up guy i am
yeah well i think what he's basically
saying is if they're firing me for
violating these ethics but they do it
every day
that was wrongful termination well
listen uh to be accused of violating
journalistic ethics don't you have to be
a journalist and don't you have to have
ethics i mean that's what i'm saying
right yeah
yeah
yeah also the idea of him accusing
anyone of breaching ethics and media oh
did they not do enough reporting on the
uh the governor of new york did they did
they not talk about him properly because
there's some kind of conflict of
interest there and they look the other
way on it that's crazy not like you
tried to help him yeah what are you
thinking right you know i was on there
three ti two or three times and and we
watched this guy remember back during
the pandemic when he was telling
everybody to wear a mask and then
there's pictures of him out in public
without a mask i mean it's unbelievable
that hypocrisy it transcends so many
parts of our culture it's unbelievable i
mean he faked being quarantined he did
he pretended he did in his basement
right yeah working out yeah when he was
actually at one of his properties in the
hampton some kind of fat tire bike rolls
up and he's like hey aren't you supposed
to be quarantined he's like who are you
and he gets in his face yeah yeah you
know i think we have a serious problem
in this country where
you know we were talking just before the
show downstairs and i i said we have a a
low light filter for the chicken city
you said we need a low life a little
life builder for congress i'll tell you
yeah and i said but that would get rid
of basically everybody maybe a handful
of people that's true and you know i'm
just thinking about
there are so many people who believe cnn
they turn it on or it's in the airport
or it's in their hotel rooms they listen
to it and they they think this stuff is
real
and and now you know even now with cuomo
coming out and being like oh yeah they
just blatantly breach ethics for ratings
they're still going to be people who
just believe what they say yeah right
and they blatantly breached ethics for
ratings have that work form by the way
hold on truth be told their ratings were
they were doing well during the trump
years oh well absolutely
you know it did work out until but even
then i don't think it was the breaching
of ethics that worked for them i think
it was just the constant trashing of
trump
and any of trump's supporters too yeah
it didn't matter about facts and exactly
and you can argue that that's absolutely
a breach of ethics but i don't think
they would ever describe it as that so
with him making these accusations i
doubt that's what he's referring to but
i mean according to chris cuomo we've
all be we've all breached ethics by
looking at the wikileaks because it's
really legal for us to do something that
was tapper wasn't no no that was
following that
yeah
said that uh it was illegal to look at
the wikileaks well my apologies to jake
tapper accusing
you yeah so uh as as somebody's in
congress though i'm sure you've dealt
with them misrepresenting your positions
tell us tell us
oh lisa that doesn't happen right i tell
you when the reporters come up and want
to stick a mic or a phone in your face
you're going uh no i think i'm fine i'll
tell you what
it is palpable the the fact that they
want to misrepresent things we say all
of the time and you all know that you
see that uh and thank god for your show
because the american public is waking up
to this
and we appreciate y'all bringing it out
it's unbelievable i'll give you one
example of a story i really like is uh
there was a guy who was accused of being
a white nationalist i asked the
journalist i said hey this guy does not
he's in a mixed-race relationship he's
got a mixed-race child and the
journalist goes is he white and i was
like yes and he goes is he a nationalist
and i said yes he was white nationalist
and i was like oh come on
that was that's you know how dirty that
is and that's that's the game they play
oh absolutely they did it to me i'm not
even anybody i was talking in a
clubhouse room once about officer
sitnick and saying that he didn't he
died from natural causes and they were
like oh
congressional staffer
blames capitol police for officer sit
next death i'm like that's not what i
said i said he died of natural causes
and then i turned out to be right you
know the article's still up there
so what is this we got at times v
sullivan we gotta we gotta
get that looked at by the supreme court
or something or what to be because right
now they can just lie
they can they can they do these really
clever tricks where they'll say fact
check there's one uh the new york times
ran saying fact check
republicans falsely accuse biden of you
know driving up gas prices and then they
they show some quotes from you know
mccarthy and from mcconnell and from i
think lindsey graham and they're like
they accused joe biden of shutting down
oil and gas leases and saying that drove
up prices but according to the experts
we've decided to talk to these two guys
they say it's wrong therefore it's a
fact check and i'm like that's an
opinion piece absolutely it is and so
this is what they do all the time they
can run opinions claim it's fact they
can outright say it is a fact that this
happened and then when they get sued
they say oh that was an opinion
and then the courts are like okay they
want to hide behind that and like you
say that ought to be tested you betcha
uh and we see that all the time what do
they call them some call them pinocchios
they give it two three four pinocchio
i mean they ought to have the most
amount of pinocchios right
yeah i guess i guess you know i also
question the washington post's pinocchio
system it's not that pinocchio would
clone himself when he lied his nose
would grow longer so maybe they would be
like his nose has grown five feet longer
and said they're like now there's more
of them right yeah well at least with
pinocchio you knew there were strings
attached oh yeah
but the washington times you got to read
that with a grain of salt assault
washington post you got to read that
with a grain of salt in times is pretty
good actually it is
this is this is weird though let me ask
you
there's a strange thing in that
conservative media has their faults they
get stories wrong but they have a
tendency to be more correct than say the
new york times how is that what what
what is this that you know my my
background was not
as a conservative republican i grew up
in chicago liberal democrat all that
stuff but my my concern is with what is
true and effective what is working and
so when i read the new york times and i
see lie after a lie i just eventually
turned it off i stopped i stopped look i
i stopped going to their site with cnn i
used to have cnn running on the running
on on in the background 24 7 while i was
working and then one day i realized they
stopped covering news and it was just
panels on with their opinions about
trump i start turning it off all of a
sudden now you know i'll google search a
story and you're more likely to find the
truth on a conservative or right-leaning
newspaper than you would at cnn msnbc
the new york times or otherwise why why
is it that's even if you can get it to
pull up like if you pull up like i'm
saying talking about office we tried
right like you talked about officer nick
you have to go to the second or third
google page to see the autopsy reports
and what the coroner actually
deemed like the fake stories are still
there you can't even try pulling up any
fox news article it doesn't even come up
well there's values in our constitution
you know this freedom of religion
freedom of press you can go right down
that list and i think conservatives
still want to live by that document that
founding document they understand how
important it is and the left not so much
they'll stretch the truth and quite
frankly there's been a lot of people
myself included that say look you guys
are trying what you're doing is going to
destroy the foundation of this country
if we stand by and let you and we
shouldn't stand by and let you i tell
people when they ask me what when they
find out i'm accomplished and they say
what party what are you republican or
democrat and i tell them i'm a christian
conservative republican and in that
order we've got a foundation for this
country the founders were brilliant in
what they set up and the left wants to
get away from it and that's part of the
problem
why
why do you so we talk about this a whole
lot but i'd be interested in your
perspective on why
the
the the left
in this country is more than just the
left you've got the establishment
democrat voices as well as the
progressive voices why why do you think
it is they want to get rid of the
constitution and those founding values
if you've got the people depending on
you you can keep getting reelected
it's pretty simple really when you think
about it it doesn't matter what party
you're in they want government to be the
answer well i'm from texas you know
we're very proud to be from texas we
were a country of our own right we get
it in texas and we don't want big
brother big government doing anything
for us don't help us please
think about it the first time we we're
guaranteed the right to a life liberty
and the pursuit
of happiness not guaranteed equal
happiness and what you're seeing now is
a government that wants to say look
we'll take care of you we'll give you
equal happiness doesn't matter what the
constitutional into
declaration of independence says we're
going to take care of you and they will
keep getting reelected i think there's a
couple things too like absolute power
corrupts absolutely but on top of that
they don't want to confront their own
morality so when they start saying like
you know i when
when their values don't or the bad
things they do don't align with society
they want to make excuses for it and and
that's why our republic is falling too
because it was meant for a virtuous
society and we are losing virtue we have
a saying for that
rules for thee
but not for me that's what you're seeing
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you